before house of the dragon there was
fire and blood will damon targaryen's
life follow the same course as the
source material here's what we know
about fire and blood's daemon targaryen
spoilers ahead
prince damon was knighted by his
grandfather king jahirus upon his 16th
birthday having already shown great
promise as a fighter around the time of
his father's passing the king bestowed
upon him would have been his father's
blade dark sister the valyrian steel
sword was one of only two that had been
passed down from targaryen to targaryen
for at least 100 years damon lost an
early tournament against his frequent
adversary sir kristin cole with dark
sister by his side but he and the
ancestral weapon got to know each other
better and damon would go on to use the
sword to conquer lands and slay his
enemies
though she died when he was only a small
child prince damon learned to ride
dragons from his mother alyssa in his
early 20s damon claimed his late uncle
eamonn's dragon karaxis himself prince
damon's newly appointed steed was an
excellent fit in terms of both
physicality and temperament like damian
caraxies was fast strong and
intimidating though he was also lean and
nimble
together they conquered the stepstones
toured the free cities of essos and
fought in the targaryen civil war that
pitted the greens against the blacks
crazies met his end during the battle
above the god's eye prince damon and
karaxis challenged aemon targaryen and
his enormous dragon veigar to fight
above the vast lake at harrenhal karaxis
took a bite to his underbelly and lost a
wing but he managed to land a fatal blow
to veigar's throat who fell dead upon
the shores of the lake a mortally
wounded caraxies died a little later
outside the walls of harrenhal
had damon's father baylon not died
suddenly from appendicitis he would have
been next in line to rule the seven
kingdoms and viserys would have
presumably succeeded him but with his
own named eragon king jaharis had to
make a decision he convened a great
council composed of the seven kingdom's
many lords to determine who should
inherit the iron throne the main choices
were between viserys the eldest child of
the man who had been the king's eldest
surviving son and leonard valerian the
only son of renise targaryen herself the
daughter of jaehaerys's firstborn aemon
daemon supported his brother's claim and
raised an army to show strength while
reynise and her rich and powerful
husband cordless valerian assembled the
fleet the council had much to deliberate
viserys was 24 years old and in his
prime he had already sired a daughter to
continue the lineage in rhaenyra on the
other hand leonard was only 7 though he
came with his father's unparalleled
fortune in the end the council decided
to name viserys the heir apparent this
allied daemon to viserys and against
corliss for a while
king jeharis passed away in his old age
freeing up the throne for king viserys
the first prince damon was appointed to
a small council first as master of coin
then as master of laws a hot-tempered
and restless prince was ill-suited to
these positions before long king viserys
gave him a job that was much more to his
liking commander of the city watch in
his new position commander damon was
finally effective the city watch was a
relatively new special palace force that
patrolled and protected the streets of
king's landing the prince whipped them
into shape and they became known as the
gold cloaks
beginning tonight king's landing will
learn to fear the colour gold during
damon's tenure as commander of the city
watch king's landing experienced a
two-year period of safety and prosperity
as he and his men personally doled out
justice the size of his personal army
plus his newfound popularity made prince
damon a more powerful player in the game
of thrones than he'd ever been before
though prince damon made enemies
throughout his life one followed him
from his brother's ascension to his
probable death sir otto hightower took
over his hand of the king when damon's
father baylon died he served king
jaherus as well as king beceres in that
capacity otto and damon butted heads
early and it was otto hightower who
suggested that king viserys remove damon
from the small council and stick him in
some largely ceremonial post
putting damon in command of the city
watch was your solution
hightower would have given anything to
keep damon away from the iron throne so
he publicly supported viserys's daughter
rhaenyra as the rightful heir though she
was a young girl again this put him at
odds with damon who believed himself to
be a more sensible candidate hightower
improved his station when king viserys
the first chose to marry his daughter
alicent after the death of aseras's
first wife but the ambitious advisor
overplayed his hand years later after
alison had given vasara's sons hightower
began to incessantly argue for their
place in the succession king viserys
grew tired of this and dismissed him
this riff would soon spill over into
civil war which would pit damon and otto
against each other yet again
damon's post with a gold cloaks meant
that he spent less time at court with
the nobles and more time with the common
folk of king's landing who lived far
outside the walls of the red keep this
wanted the affection of citizens
throughout the kingdom who bestowed upon
him a new unofficial title prince of the
city but since daemon could so often be
found in the city's many establishments
of ill-repute he earned himself a second
nickname lord flee bottom his behavior
became a point of contention between him
and his brother the king the prince
further upset his brother when he was
overheard drunkenly mocking viserys
newborn son who had died within a day of
his birth the heir for a day
did you say it
this was a slight too far king viserys
officially named renera princess of
dragonstone and his heir essentially
cutting his brother out of the line of
succession
of all the titles and superlatives that
damon targaryen collected throughout his
life the rogue prince was the one that
stuck being a second born son of a
second born son damon always knew he was
a long shot for the iron throne but that
didn't mean he wanted it any less
however if he couldn't be prince of
dragonstone and didn't have an immediate
path to the crown at king's landing he'd
take any kingdom he could get damon and
his former rival at the great council
corliss valerian joined together to
conquer the stepstones a chain of
islands east of dorne that had been
troubled by piracy the land itself
didn't make for much of a kingdom but
the stepson's location made them
important to lucrative sea trade which
interested corliss with karaxi's dark
sister and a mighty fleet daemon
declared himself king of the stepstones
in the narrow sea corliss even made him
a crown and king vasara supported his
brother playing at war because it kept
him away from king's landing later he
tried to insert himself at runestone
which had been his first wife's seat of
power in the veil of aaron he was not
well liked by the people of the veil
mostly on account of how nasty he had
been to his wife he was not only refused
the throne at runestone but turned away
from the veil altogether which left him
in an increasingly weakened position
like most noble men of his day damon
used marriage as a political tool his
first wife was chosen for him by his
grandmother who used his patrol to lady
raya royce to strengthen king's landings
hold over the veil of aaron on paper
damon and rhea were a solid match in
person they hated each other and quickly
became estranged he returned to his home
city and pleaded with his brother to
dissolve their union but the king
refused when reya died in a fall from
her horse damon asked cordless valerian
for his daughter lena's hand in marriage
taking lena as his princess would tie
him to the richest and one of the most
influential families in the seven
kingdoms she was however promised to
another man but that was no matter damon
handedly slew him in a duel to claim
lena as his wife the wedding offended
king viserys who hadn't given the pair
his blessing first as was customary
becerra saw the marriage for what it was
a chance for damon to improve his
standing this was a better match that
resulted in twin daughters but lena and
what would have been damon's first son
both lost their lives in childbirth
rhaenyra targaryen had been favored by
the king over his brother which should
have made them enemies but uncle and
niece were always fond of each other
when he traveled he would bring her back
exotic souvenirs prior to his second
marriage it was rumored that the two had
begun an affair which caused yet another
rift between the rogue prince and the
king who considered having his brother
executed viserys insisted that his
daughter marry corliss valerian's son
lenore lenore had been the other
claimant to the throne of the great
council and viserys thought it prudent
to tie up any loose threats to his
family's supremacy rhaenyra relented but
was unfulfilled as lenar was almost
certainly gay though the couple did have
three sons they were allegedly fathered
by her tournament champion sir farwin
strong for short time damon and rhaenyra
were wedded to siblings lena and lana
valarian and the foursome got along well
however shortly after lena died in labor
lanor was killed in a suspicious
incident while with a traveling
companion gossip held that damon had
paid the assassin so that he could marry
a widowed rhaenyra there wasn't proof
but the prince and princess did wed
their union wasn't controversial because
of their blood relation or age
difference but because again they didn't
ask the king's permission and they
didn't mourn for six months before tying
the knot
as the largely peaceful reign of king
viserys the first drew to its clothes
the aegean monarch realized he had a
looming crisis on his hands he named his
eldest daughter rhaenyra as his heir but
she was a woman with what might be
bastard children now married to his
scheming little brother his wife alison
hightower maneuvered to have her sons
aegon and eamonn moved up the line of
succession they were boys legitimately
born to the king but beceres found the
hightower family's naked ambition
distasteful two factions emerged the
greens and the blacks so named for the
color of the dresses worn by queen
allison hightower and princess rhaenyra
targaryen at a party to celebrate the
king and queen's fifth anniversary being
married to the princess and heir
apparent put damon squarely on the side
of the blacks along with corliss
valerian and his wife renise the greens
had amongst their ranks otto hightower
and sir kristin cole tensions would
simmer until the king died and a small
council failed to agree upon a successor
when kristin murdered one of rhaenyra's
backers at a council meeting the war
began in earnest damon who stood to be
at least prince regent and perhaps even
see his sons with rhaenyra sent to the
throne one day fought and won important
victories for his wife upon his dragon
karaxis but the war would end in a
bloody mess that's on either rhaenyra
nor aegon wearing the true crown
the last record of prince damon's
existence is the account of the battle
above the god's eye where he and his
dragon battled against aemond and his
own dragon ultimately both dragons and
the riders plummeted to the lake below
all meeting their deaths or so the
history books say eamon's body along
with dark sister was recovered but
prince damon's remains were never found
rumors that he survived the fight spread
but it's far more likely that the battle
above the god's eye was his final act
[Music]